in the last lecture we spent time
talking about the mean or expectation
and its properties most important one
being linearity but let's step back now
and think about what is it that the mean
means why do we care about it we have
this intuitive idea that if you do
things long enough if you keep
experimenting with the same random
variable collecting its values its
long-run average will be about the same
as its mean now we're gonna try to make
that more precise so we're gonna talk
about the topic of deviation from the
mean or as I like to say what does the
mean really mean why do we care about it
well let's look at an example that's
familiar to get a grip on the specific
ideas that were interested in so suppose
I toss a fair coin 101 times then I know
that the expected number since then all
the values from 0 through 101 are
possible and the middle value is the
expectation it's 50 and a half heads now
I'm never gonna get exactly 50 and a
half heads the probability in 101 flips
of getting 50 150 and a half heads is 0
because there's no way to flip half a
head so you don't expect the expectation
in that sense know given measurement
know given experiment is gonna yield the
expectation the expectation is this
thing that we expect to come out on the
average well we can ask what's the
probability of getting as close as you
could hope to get to the expectation
namely what's the probability of getting
exactly 50 heads and it's about 113th or
if you ask what's the probability of
getting either 50 or 51 heads but being
within plus or minus one of the
expectation it's about 1/7 okay let's
flip more coins and see what happens
this time I'm going to flip a thousand
in 1 coins and again the expected number
of heads is five hundred and a half
which I'll never get exactly the
probability of getting exactly 500 heads
is 139th and the probability of getting
within one of the expectation that is
500 or 501 heads is about 119th now
these numbers have gone down from the
previous numbers remember it was about
1/7 and we've gone down to 119 so it's
actually we're less likely to be within
a fixed distance within one of the
expectation when we flip more coins so
as the number of tosses grows the number
of heads guess what gets less likely to
be within any given fixed distance of
the mean but things get better when we
start looking at percentages so what's
the probability of being within 1% of
the mean if I toss a thousand and one
coins
well 1% of a thousand 1 is about 10 so
we're talking about one percent of the
thousand and one and the probability of
being within 10 of 505 that is to say
the probability of being within 510 and
490 is about 0.49
it's almost 50/50 which is not really so
bad so we have a 50/50 chance of
actually being within 1% of the expected
number when I flip a thousand and one
coins so we can start to say is that
when we're trying to give the meaning to
the mean if I let you be the standard
abbreviation for expectation of all I'm
doing that just so it'll fit on the
slide nicely in formulas so mu is the
expectation of R the basic question
we're asking is two basic questions one
is what's the probability that the
random variable is far from its mean mu
and you could phrase that as what's the
probability that the distance from R to
MU the absolute value of R minus mu is
greater than someone mouths X and the
second question that we want to ask is
what's the average deviation what's the
expectation of the distance between R -
Bo what's the expected value of R minus
mu now of course we're trying to make
sense of the meaning of the expectation
in terms of the expectation of the
distance between R and s expectations so
there's a little bit of circularity
there but let's live with it and proceed
let's look at an example to crystallize
the ideas a little let's look at two
dice with the same mean the green dye is
gonna be a fair a standard fair die in
which each of the numbers one through
six has an equal probability of showing
up and it's expected expected value is
exactly gonna be the midpoint between
one and six or three and a half now
suppose I look at a loaded die or die -
which only throws a 1 or a 6
but with equal probability then its
expectation is also three and a half by
the same reasoning so here at these two
different die one takes the values one
through six equally likely and the other
takes only the two values one in six but
they have the same expectation so how do
I capture the difference well if I look
at the expected distance of the fair die
to its mean I claim it's one and a half
but the expected distance of the loaded
die from its mean same mean remember
three and a half is actually two and a
half in fact the second die is always
exactly two and a half from its expected
value let's look at the PDFs to get a
grip on understanding what's going on so
here's the PDF for the fair die the over
one through six the probability is 1/6
so each of those green spikes is columns
is 1/6 a high and their total is the one
as the probability that the fair die
takes one of those values 1 through 6
with equally likely with equal
likelihood now the expected value is
exactly in the middle at three and a
half and the average distance of these
points well you can see that a third of
the time you're a distance a half a
third of the time that is when you take
the values two and five you are distance
exactly one and a half and another third
of the time you're at distance two and a
half when you take one in six and that
averages out to the middle value of one
and a half
so the expected deviation the expected
distance of the fair died from its mean
is one and a half on the other hand for
the loaded die as we said it's always
exactly two and a half from its expected
value which means it's expected value is
also two and a half so we can start to
see the difference between these two of
distributions and these two kinds of die
by even though they have the same
expectation one of them is more likely
and has a greater expected distance from
its mean and the moral of this short
piece is that the mean alone is not a
good predictor of a random variables
behavior as you might suppose one
parameter one number is not going to
capture the shape of a PDF which gives
you the more full information about the
distribution of values of a random
variable and we need some more
information than just the expectation
and an especially valuable extra piece
of information that's still well less
than the overall shape of the PDF of the
random variable is knowing it's probable
deviation from its mean